est-ce que votre père a dit l'intendance
suivra qui est une phrase absolument
faux ah c'est faux il a toujours
considéré que la tendance précédait
le bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir donc pourquoi mais non
amiral vous l'avez vous la légende de
nerveux tout à fait voilà ce qu'il a
fait il a porté la Légion d'Honneur
alors qu'il l'a pas ouais moi je le
dénonce
cheveux très très court en 40
alors fils de Gaulle bonsoir à 82 ans
vous devenez une star une star de
l'édition en révélant votre père sous un
jour inédit le premier tome de De Gaulle
mon père donc vous êtes venus par les
ici à la fin du mois d'octobre c'est
vendu à 500 000 exemplaires c'est un
carton énorme
500 000 exemplaires c'est très très rare
dans l'édition de nos jours et le
deuxième tome paraît-il se vend mieux
donc encore bravo je pense vous allez
faire un million au minimum avec les
deux tomes voilà est-ce que vous êtes
heureux
tout à fait oui puisque c'est un
témoignage que j'ai
c'est un témoignage qui va porter j'en
suis heureux je suis heureux que Michel
toriac mais posait les questions de
telle manière que il me il m'incitait à
parler de ce que j'avais gardé en
réserve parce que c'était la réserve de
mes parents aussi de mon père et de ma
mère j'ai lu le dossier à fond et son
père était président de la République
personne en public même pas votre mère
et quand votre père meurt vous vous
penchez sur son corps c'est la première
fois d'ailleurs que vous le voyez sans
sans cravate et vous lui toucher
l'arrière de la tête pour voir s'il a la
même bosse que vous c'est à dire que
jamais de votre vie vous n'aviez touché
la tête de votre père non jamais de ma
vie sauf mort étendu sur sur la couche
sur lequel on l'avait mis ainsi je les
touchais j'ai constaté que nous avions
le même méplat au même endroit alors
donc de Gaulle mon père tome 2 le retour
couvre les 10 dernières années de la vie
du général de son retour au pouvoir en
58 jusqu'à sa mort alors ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est quand il s'installe
à l'Elysée il aime pas l'Élysée il
trouve ça étriqué il dit qu'il y a pas
de vue c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement ce
qui les met dans un château c'est qu'on
puisse le voir de loin et là il dit que
finalement il est encastré dans la rue
du bourg-saint-honoré et ça lui plaît
pas du tout il pense à un moment à aller
s'installer au château de Vincennes il y
avait trop de travaux à faire
tout à fait ça aurait été très difficile
il y a des murs qui font plusieurs
mètres d'épaisseur pour faire passer des
conduites électriques ou des conduites
d'eau c'est pas évident en effet bien
alors donc on vous parents arrivent à
l'Élysée ils apportent le style de vie
très spartiate de la propriété que vous
avez qui s'appelle la boiserie pas de
gaspillage chez vous de Gaulle tenez à
tout payer et il éteignait les lumières
quand il sortait des pièces oui mais
c'était aussi la culture de son milieu
tant de son côté à lui que du côté de ma
mère ce qui est extraordinaire avec
votre père aussi c'est que par exemple
quand il allait dans un hôtel et qu'il
était invité il demandait le montant de
la facture et il donnait une somme
équivalente au personnel en pourboire
c'est tout à fait vrai vous vous êtes
exactement pareil parce que un jour vous
travaillez avec Michèle toriac sur les
deux bouquins et puis son ordinateur
explose parce que bon il est plein de
données et vous lui faites un chèque
pour qu'il se rachète le même ordinateur
mais pourquoi vous a-t-il dit cela il
n'a pas accepté ce chèque ce qui est
extraordinaire aussi avec l'amiral quand
il a des questions de droit d'auteur par
exemple vous l'avez proposé de partager
les droits d'auteur avec lui à 55 ans
quoi
c'est pas tout à fait cela mais c'est
s'en est proche alors vous racontez donc
dans ce livre l'oeuf politique du
général a commencé par la réconciliation
franco-allemande il invite le chancelier
Adenauer en 1958 à la boiserie ce qui
était extraordinaire parce que c'était
13 ans finalement après après la
Libération après l'occupation après la
déportation et à ce moment-là il y a
deux personnes de la boiserie 2z
ménagères qui refusent de servir le
chancelier Adenauer oui l'unité
alsacienne
la seconde était Lorraine
et elle avait ressenti de langue
française entièrement et ressenti
l'invasion allemande comme une invasion
qu'elle était chef deux ans plus tard en
1960 il dit à coup de chef quelque chose
de très prémonitoire il dit le
capitalisme le communisme tout ça sera
rattrapé par la technologie et ça sera
le mondialisme c'est-à-dire que il y a
plus de 40 ans il avait déjà cette
notion finalement j'y va dépasser toutes
les théories
philosophiques ou
qu'on avait pu concevoir auparavant
certaines datant de 1850 alors votre
père était quand même sûr amiral de la
disparition du communisme et disait
d'ailleurs toujours la Russie disait pas
l'URSS et il disait la Russie boira le
communisme comme le buvard boil l'encre
c'est-à-dire qu'il était persuadé non
seulement la disparition du communisme
mais aussi de la réunification de
l'Allemagne il l'avait dit à l'époque de
la visite d'adenaware donc il est quand
même un mais une vraie Vista historique
oui c'est une une analyse historique il
en avait l'habitude il faisait aussi des
analyses opérationnelles les calculs
opérationnels en 1940 pour savoir si la
Grande-Bretagne pouvait résister ou non
alors on disait que votre père était
visionnaire enfin sur l'Algérie il a été
moins visionné il a été beaucoup plus
pragmatique parce que vous affirmez
complètement dans votre bouquin à la
thèse selon laquelle de Gaulle avait
tout prévu depuis je vous ai compris
jusque aux accords d'Évian c'est à dire
qu'on a souvent dit qu'en fait il avait
joué un double jeu quand il disait pas
du tout mais si je jouais pas le double
jeu en disant je vous ai compris vive
l'Algérie française ça veut dire qu'il
pensait en 58 que l'Algérie pouvait
rester française
il est revenu voir ce qui se passait en
Algérie et là il est tombé sur un
désarroi total de la rébellion
algérienne qui a envoyé des émissaires
en se disant si le général de Gaulle
revient
comme perdus autant arrêter la rébellion
tout de suite ils ont envoyé des
émissaires et en même temps il voyait
sur toutes les places en particulier à
Mostaganem où il y avait beaucoup très
grande majorité de musulmans il a
entendu tout le monde criait Algérie
français il se dit peut-être moi je
pense que c'est trop tard mais peut-être
y a-t-il une chance alors je vais
l'essayer on va voir et il a mis tout au
dessus avec le plan de Constantine
c'est-à-dire la maîtrise des opérations
reprendre le dessus sur le terrain
militairement le les construire des HLM
des ports des aérodromes des routes des
écoles il a mis tout dessus il y avait
plus un saut pour la métropole tout
était sur l'Algérie
au bout d'un an
il a vu que ça n'arrivait pas il
n'arrivait pas à faire basculer
[Musique]
les Algériens de notre côté du côté
français parce que les français malgré
la bonne volonté de la plupart
à partir du moment où vous êtes obligé
de vos livrets à des opérations de
police à faire des vérifications
d'identité à rentrer dans les maisons ou
les villages même les gens qui sont pour
vous finissent par être
exaspérés ou vexé et par conséquent vous
les retournez contre eux et la
population algérienne était en train
progressivement de plus en plus de
s'écarter de nous sinon de d'être contre
nous alors
au bout d'un an il a vu que ça ne
marchait pas et au bout de 18 mois il a
dit donc je vais essayer une Algérie
algérienne mais on le disant à chaque
fois dans une conférence de presse il
l'a trompé personne tous les trois mois
elle faisait une conférence de presse
qui durait une heure et demie personne
ne le faisait il a été déçu amiral par
les pieds-noirs qui ont refusé de
partager le pouvoir et il pense
d'ailleurs que ils se sont suicidés en
fait avec l'OS ils pensaient ça c'était
un suicide en effet et après ils se sont
rapatriés ou apatriés en panique en
laissant tout le Front de libération
nationale ne souhaitait pas le départ
des
pieds-noirs car il se rendrait bien
compte qu'ils avaient besoin de leur
savoir-faire technique et administratif
pour démarrer un autre état et c'était
une des raisons ce départ disons de la
ruine de l'Algérie après le départ des
Français
votre père n'est jamais retourné en
Algérie après jamais un père n'est
jamais retourné en Algérie voilà alors
vous racontez aussi amiral la première
bombe atomique française qu'on a appelé
facilement la bominette la bombe
le Canard Enchaîné mais c'est fait
pourrir le Canard Enchaîné voilà pour
autre chose ben oui donc l'ambassadeur
soviétique dit au général de Gaulle si
nous occupons en bourre vous ne bougerez
pas car on enverra une bombe sur
Marseille et de Gaulle répond à ce
moment-là maintenant
et c'était assez fort parce que la
France redevenait à ce moment-là une
puissance mondiale ce qu'elle avait
cessé d'être lors de la défaite de 1940
quoi c'est vrai la France n'existait
plus internationalement
bien que à la fin de la guerre en 45
elle avait plus de monde sur le terrain
entre les Allemands que les Anglais vous
racontez aussi amiral les attentats qui
ont été dirigés contre votre père
notamment celui du Petit Clamart qui a
été sans doute un des plus périlleux
dans la dizaine qui ont eu lieu et alors
après la fusillade optique Lamar il sort
de la voiture il dit cette fois c'était
tangent et il ajoute ils ont vraiment
tiré comme des cochons chez tout à fait
vrai votre mère a dit c'est
extraordinaire votre mère dit à ce
moment-là juste après l'attentat elle
était avec votre père la voiture elle
dit j'espère que les poulets n'ont rien
et à ce moment-là il y a les deux flics
qui se regardent et en fait c'était
c'était des poulets qui étaient dans le
coffre de la voiture elle faisait du
souci pour les poulets
du lendemain avec Pompidou à la boiserie
et et
l'anecdote est authentique c'est
l'interprétation était René mais de
limitation est très mauvaise
alors vous parlez aussi amiral de
l'antisémitisme supposé du général de
Gaulle alors vous dit d'abord qu'il
était de refusard comme son père il
avait pris la défense de Dreyfus il
disait volontiers en parlant des Juifs
c'est la communauté la plus intelligente
de la terre mais ce qui a c'est qui
supportaient pas qu'on culpabilise le
peuple français au nom du martyr juif
c'était quelque chose qui les Français
se sont quand même battus les armes à la
main contre un système
qui lui voulait sinon
exterminer les Juifs du moins les
chasser
les Français sont battus les armes
amiral c'est quand même un peu la vision
gaulliste ça veut dire que les Français
sont battus par la guerre avec un 90%
des Français qui ont rien foutu pendant
la guerre ils ont attendu que ça 90% ou
plus ou plus oui enfin il y a eu quand
même quelques résistances et quelques
centaines de milliers de gens qui les
ont aidés qui donc aurait risqué quelque
chose quand vous dites qu'il voulait pas
qu'on culpab le peuple français au nom
du martyr juif c'est au nom de la
légende gaulliste parce qu'en fait c'est
vrai quand même que les Français ont
quand même des choses à se reprocher par
rapport à cette époque les Français ne
sont pas antisémites ils n'ont jamais
été vous croyez dans les années 30 il y
avait pas essayer de les culpabiliser ça
mon père est une d'ailleurs de personne
hein ça soit du côté opposé outils mon
père ne mettait pas qu'on culpabilise
les français
si quelqu'un essayait de le faire en
même temps
il disait que c'était devo en même temps
en temps
je voulais rien quand votre père est
arrivé au pouvoir il a trouvé Maurice
Papon qui était en poste et qui avait
été blanchi par deux jurides résistants
notoires mais lui qui savait ce qui
s'était passé pendant la guerre pourquoi
la pourquoi a-t-il gardé Papon Papon
était en préfet de police de Paris et
parce qu'il faisait son métier donc on
l'a laissé et puisque il faisait son
métier donc il allait enfin
l'affectation et puisque les deux jurys
de la résistance car il a aussi rendu
des services la résistance ne l'avez pas
condamné pour mon père qu'une n'avait
pas de raison de le condamner plus qu'un
autre parce que il savait très bien mon
père ce qui s'était passé en France
il ne voulait pas susciter des
polémiques indéfinis des uns contre les
autres vous savez s'il avait fallu
prendre à partie tous les gens qui ont
transporté des Juifs d'un endroit ou
d'un autre en France je précise
alors à ce moment là il fallait inculper
les conducteurs de bûches les chemins de
fer
etc ça fait beaucoup de gens qui leur a
fallu inculper en France à ce moment là
encore que et je précise les Français
ont beaucoup plus protégé les Juifs que
ils n'en ont livré si il y en a qui ont
été livrés
et dont beaucoup ont pu échapper avec
souvent la complicité de la police
alors quand la guerre des Six Jours
éclate en 1967 le général de Gaulle
prend ses distances avec l'État d'Israël
et à ce moment-là Golda mère qui
dirigeait l'État d'Israël dit ce qui ne
sont pas avec nous sont contre nous et
c'est là que votre père a cette phrase
qui lui a beaucoup été reproché vous le
savez en parlant des Juifs il a dit les
Juifs un peuple d'élite dominateur et
sur de soi alors il paraît dites-vous
dans votre bouquin que dans sa bouche
c'était un compliment mais ça a été vécu
par les Juifs de France l'opposition
immédiatement pareil de cette phrase
pour la tronquer mais vous savez à
l'époque ça faisait pas tellement de
polémiques
spécialistes moi je me souviens je me
souviens d'un dessin j'ai un dessin dans
l'Express de Tim grand dessinateur où il
montrait un juif dans un camp de
concentration avec marqué dessous un
peuple d'élite dominateur et sur de soi
c'était si quand même combien de
décennies avant que de Gaulle combattait
qui
combat et pour pour empêcher mais vous
voulez dire que votre père ayant été le
général de Gaulle à Londres pouvaient se
permettre de dire ça il y a que il est
comme Madame Golda Meyer et d'abord
passé aux États-Unis
avant la guerre préventive par l'État
d'Israël c'est livré et puis les
États-Unis étaient en campagne
électorale présidentielle
les Américains sont très mécontents
quand on les dérange on demande une
campagne présidentielle pour eux c'est
capital donc ils n'ont rien dit à Madame
Golda Meyer madame goldameyer est passé
ensuite en France elle a demandé la vie
du général de Gaulle le général de
Gaulle a dit je suis opposé à toute
espèce de conflit au Moyen-Orient aussi
bien vous
l'État israélien que tous les autres
États autour et quand ce conflit
a éclaté
il a arrêté tout ce que nous
fournissions aux uns et aux autres mais
d'un côté comme de l'autre
car il ne voulait pas de conflit au
Moyen-Orient il était présent
il a dit à madame goldameyer vous allez
vous êtes plus fort donc vous allez
conquérir des territoires mais après
comme vous allez faire une coalition
contre vous de gens qui ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux vous serez obligé un
jour ou l'autre de l'évacuer et vous
allez être gêné je ne vous approuve pas
dans cette c'est à ce moment-là que
Madame Golda Meyer qui avait une qui
était une femme de détermination et
d'énergie a dit bon bah puisque vous
êtes pas pour nous vous êtes contre nous
c'est tout de même un peu abusif comme
raisonnement mon père a dit mais c'est
un peuple d'élite mais en ce moment il
est sûr de soi il dominateur voilà
donc on arrive à Mira en 1968 alors là
votre père en 1968 faut le dire est un
petit peu dépassé par les événements il
y a une crise mondiale à ce moment-là
qui touche les étudiants du monde entier
mais lui il pensait que que l'abondance
la protection sociale les avancées
technologiques mettrai la France à
l'abri et en fait il s'aperçoit à ce
moment-là que c'est sérieux en France 68
et il se reproche à lui-même d'avoir un
petit peu donner trop d'importance à sa
politique étrangère il dit le seul
responsable c'est moi c'est-à-dire c'est
extraordinaire parce qu'il était capable
de reconnaître effectivement ces
erreurs et vous et là vous lui dites un
truc tout à fait rare vous lui dites
papa il faut bien voir qu'à terme votre
règne est finie
j'ai appris ça en lisant votre le
deuxième tome mais j'aurais jamais cru
que vous osiez dire ça à votre père
parce que c'est fort à ce moment là
j'étais capitaine de vaisseau j'avais
presque l'âge des ministres maintenant
vous lui dites papa il faut bien voir
qu'à terme votre votre règne est finie
et c'est la première fois que vous lui
jetez comme ça une vérité à la tête oui
mais en réalité il l'a bien réalisé moi
je commence à être lassé du peuple
français et le peuple français est sans
doute lassé de moi alors ce qui est très
très touchant dans dans votre bouquin
c'est quand vous lui jetez cette vérité
à la tête pour la première fois vous
entendez de sa part un aveu de faiblesse
et c'est moi la première fois en tous
les cas que que je lis quelque chose de
tel au sujet du général de Gaulle il
vous dit ne me décourage pas
oui il a sans doute dit la même chose à
ma mère parce que je pense que nous
avons été à deux de lui dire directement
extraordinaire entendre le général de
Gaulle dire ne me décourage pas c'est
même décourage pas oui je ne peux quand
même pas laisser la France n'importe
comment n'importe qui et alors là il y a
le fameux épisode de Baden Baden donc
qui est une ville allemande qu'elle
époque était encore une garnison
française alors on a souvent comparé le
voyage à Baden-Baden au départ de Louis
XVI de la fuite à Varenne pour vous pas
du tout vous dites c'est un stratagème
c'est-à-dire c'est pas du tout une fuite
c'est en fait une façon de faire subir
un électrochoc aux Français et une façon
aussi de désarçonner l'adversaire
c'est vrai tu le touchef doit avoir une
manœuvre dont il ne fait pas à personne
mais en même temps c'était une menace
clairement exprimé pourquoi aller chez
massue qui était le plus fracassant de
tous s'il avait voulu c'est ce qui fait
il serait pas passé chez Mathieu donc
lorsqu'il part lorsqu'il part à Baden
vous dit c'est un stratagème en fait
pour désasonner l'adversaire
massue a longtemps dit maintenant il est
mort il peut pas dire le contraire mais
il a toujours dit que le général de
Gaulle avait perdu les pédales et qu'il
était venu en fait à Baden Baden pour
chercher du secours pour chercher de
l'aide parce qu'il était complètement
découragé il était prêt à abandonner le
pouvoir et que lui il m'a su a dû
remonter le moral cette semaine dans le
journal Le Point il y a le colonel
Richard qui était l'aide de camp de
massue qui est pas d'accord avec la
version que vous donnez dans votre
bouquin il dit que lui il était là-bas
il a je sais que massue a eu du mal à
convaincre votre père de rester au
pouvoir qu'en fait votre père voulait
démissionner et qu'il y a eu deux
entretiens et non pas un comme vous
dites dans votre bouquin et qu'il a
fallu vraiment le convaincre de rester
au pouvoir vous lui répondez quoi à ce
colonel Richard Richard qui n'était
peut-être pas gaulliste au départ je
veux dire
le Richard a voulu défendre son patron
après des ouvrages comme dit rappelle
Pierre Messmer qui ont été édités
longtemps après selon sa version
après oui bien alors voilà ça s'appelle
de Gaulle mon père c'est le tome 2 c'est
passionnant parce que ça touche une
période plus récente encore que le tome
c'est publié chez plomb alors vous
tordez le coup a beaucoup de rumeurs
dans dans ce bouquin amiral et puis
aussi un certain nombre de citations
donc on va voir les citations qui sont
de votre père ou celle qui ne sont pas
de votre père et on va faire une
interview papa a dit
[Musique]
alors
Amira est-ce que votre père a dit mon
seul rival c'est un temps
je crois qu'il l'a dit c'est malheureux
qui ne veut pas se laisser avoir par les
plus grands voilà ils sont je ne sais
pas s'ils connaissent Tintin c'est l'âge
de mes enfants
est-ce que votre père a dit on ne
devrait pas accepter de responsabilité
suprême au-delà de 60 ans
non il n'a pas dit cela c'est vraiment
pour nous et un homme qui écoutait aux
portes quelquefois entendait mal
est-ce que votre père a dit toute ma vie
je me suis fait une certaine idée de la
France tout à fait tout à fait est-ce
qu'il a dit toute ma vie j'ai rêvé
d'être une hôtesse de l'air non ça c'est
du tronc une canne alors oui est-ce
qu'il a dit si tous les Arabes d'Algérie
sont considérés comme français colomber
les deux églises va devenir colomber les
deux mosquées non il n'a pas dit cela
c'est perfide qui le rapport perfide qui
était un ami n'a pas bien traité de
sujets
qui est celui de l'Algérie et
le deuxième point c'est le Sénat il
était sénateur en même temps que j'ai
été Amir est-ce que votre père a dit
pour faire le blocus de Monaco il suffit
de deux panneaux de sens interdit
je crois pas qu'il est dit de cette
façon il le pensait ça non non un moment
Monaco a bougé un peu il a quand même
fermé la frontière que c'est qu'avec la
princesse de Monaco de l'époque était
américaine d'origine commençait à
s'établir une brève une une arrivée
d'affaires des États-Unis
il faut pas oublier que le premier
ministre monégasque c'est quand même un
préfet nommé par la France est-ce que
votre père a dit François Mitterrand a
tout pour être un excellent comédien oui
il l'a dit cela il m'a dit François
mitrand il disait monsieur Mitterrand ou
François Mitterrand
François Mitterrand a beaucoup de talent
c'est un prince de la parole de
l'illusion est-ce que votre père a dit
l'intendance suivra qui est une phrase
absolument faux assez faux il a toujours
considéré que la tendance précédait
pourriez-vous à mon panache blanc
n'avait pas non plus de panache blanc ni
Monaco ni panache il a rien vu est-ce
que votre père a dit
est-ce que votre père a dit s'il est
convolé Chirac se réchauffe d'escadrille
non ça c'est au diable
comment voulez-vous gouverner un pays où
il existe 300 variétés de fromage il a
dit ça oui
à l'époque
il y avait pas il y avait pas de petit
Louis est-ce que votre père a dit tout
ce que j'espère c'est qu'on donnera
jamais mon nom à un porte-avion il n'a
pas il sait pas occupé de cela c'était
l'affaire des Français après lui c'était
plus la sienne il a dit vive le Québec
libre ça c'est vrai c'est indéniable
il savait pas très bien quoi dire il a
vu tous ses québécois réunis la divine
le Québec
à chaque fois il répétait ce que la
foule disait bah chez l'enthousiasme des
Français libre est-ce que votre père a
dit mort à Céline Dion non mon père me
disait jamais mort de quelqu'un c'est la
personne c'est le sort qui en décide
ah oui amiral je voulais vous dire
quelque chose
Jamel Debbouze qui vient à la fin de
l'émission rassurez-vous il va pas
débarquer tout de suite il vient vous
serez déjà parti malheureusement est-ce
que vous avez une question à lui poser à
Jamel
si j'ai une question à lui poser en
regardant en regardant votre caméra
parce qu'on lui diffusera tout à l'heure
non parce que il a tout le succès que
que son talent en mérite et c'est très
bien ainsi car c'est un homme d'esprit
je me suis aperçu qu'il avait beaucoup
d'esprit ça lui fera plaisir ah oui par
exemple quand il m'a dit ah moi je
débarque à Roissy Charles de Gaulle
qu'est-ce que vous devez toucher comme
droit d'auteur
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu